bonsoir benoît muracciole merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur arte france alors
on l'a vu un les frappes de la coalition
semble s'intensifier depuis le début de
la semaine
pourquoi comment on peut l'expliquer en
tout cas
la situation de la ville elle-même la
situation de la ville de marib est d'un
point de vue stratégique très importante
elle est à quelques 300 kilomètres de la
frontière saoudienne elle est à moins de
100 km de la capitale des houthis n'a
donc
pour les deux camps elle revêt louis une
importance stratégique importe voilà une
importance stratégique
le problème qu'il y a cinq ans il ya des
soldats et des militaires qui veulent
s'affronter entre c'est une chose le
problème c'est que la population
continue d'être prise en otage de
stratégie qu'il ne faut absolument aucun
cas de respect des droits de l'homme les
plus élémentaires
azer a dénoncé les crimes de guerre et
les crimes contre l'humanité donc la
coalition dirigée par l'arabie saoudite
et les émirats arabes unis étaient
responsables
et pour l'instant
depuis enfin pour l'instant depuis 2015
jusqu'à maintenant les moyens utilisés
de part et d'autre des deux camps
continuent de faire fi de la situation
humanitaire à benoît seul est ce qu'on
sait plus ou moins à pourquoi la
situation a dégénéré l'a vraiment depuis
le puits de trois jours depuis le début
la fin
donc je suis je suis pas au courant
peut-être que d'autres spécialistes le
savent mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
ya toujours une question pour le mohamed
ben salman est sans doute pour une bête
zaien même si les émirats arabes unis
disent qu'ils se sont retirés du conflit
ce qui est dans la pratique faut il ya
toujours des échéances un petit peu
nationale mohamed ben salman parce qu'il
comptait sur la guerre au yémen pour
asseoir son autorité sur son pouvoir sur
l'arabie séoudite et mitraillettes parce
que ils comptés
lui aussi
a grandi enfin l'affluence des émirats
arabes unis dans la région en prenant
notamment le contrôle des ports et de
deal qui appartiennent au yémen donc
pour cela on sent bien que il ya une
urgence en ce moment de la partie de la
part des outils de support donc il ya
sans doute aussi des raisons assez
précise bien que sur le plan stratégique
la stratégie des pays qui sont engagés
dans ce conflit est assez difficile à
lire à part celle de
deux d'éliminer un maximum de civils
parce que
les nations-unies parle de plus de 230
mille morts
dans ce conflit les grands pays
occidentaux
producteurs d'armes comme la france
continue
d'alimenter ce conflit notamment avec
les entreprises thales dassault safran
mbd à
airbus les touts les bombardements qui
se fond puisque les les états unis ont
enlevé leurs avions ravitailleurs tous
les bombardements se font avec l'aide
des mrtt a330 d'airbus
qui donc participent à ces crimes de
guerre et des crimes contre l'humanité
alors des civils parlons-en on lisait la
communauté internationale craint le pire
vous le lisiez également des centaines
de milliers de civils qui ont été
déplacées depuis le début du conflit
quels sont les retours que l'on a
aujourd'hui la part des ong sur place
je peux pas vous le dire parce que nous
sommes pas au contact direct avec eux
les ong sur place il faudrait il faudra
les interroger on a quand même des
rapports de boîte à l'un d'eux le ng ml
tu mois tana qui reproche d'ailleurs ce
que nous avons dit dans notre rapport
sur les crimes contre l'humanité
c'est-à-dire qu'il y ait une tactique de
part et d'autre de
d'assèchement de d'une politique de
si l'appel star v chine c'est à dire qu
on affame le peuple on empêche les
agriculteurs d'aller cultiver les champs
on bombarde les champs on bombarde les
stations d'eau qui permettent aux
populations de de se désaltérer de boire
on attaque on empêche les convois
humanitaires d'arriver et d'apporter de
la nourriture les dernières estimations
du programme alimentaire mondial parlé
de 400 mille enfants morts en situation
de l'horrible ondes aujourd'hui au yémen
donc on se rend compte que d'un côté il
y a les beaux discours notamment de
président de la république monsieur
macron en disant oui il faut cesser les
combats et d'autre part une pratique qui
au contraire les alimentent et qui
plonge une fois encore la population
yéménite dans une situation absolument
effroyable en lisant la communauté
internationale qui s'inquiète de la
situation humanitaire sur place quel est
mon rôle que peut jouer la communauté
internationale dans dance est dans cette
affaire dans cette histoire
bien de points qu'il nous semble
important dans cette dans cette
situation c'est d'une part
la création d'un groupe d'experts d'
enquête des nations unies d'experts
indépendants et médoc est pas seulement
des gens qui observent mais qui ont les
moyens d' enquête comme ça s'est fait en
syrie par exemple
ensuite c'est ce qu'avait demandé le
groupe d'éminents experts dans les
derniers rapports c'est à dire que les
la grande bretagne la france
les etats-unis la belgique que l'espagne
enfin nombreux pays comme ça de l'union
européenne l'italie cesse de d'envoyer
des armes aux pays de la coalition il ya
une loi toute simple dans tous les
conflits ne fait pas
r sans avoir les armes de faire le guet
merci beaucoup benoît mourad jeunes
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir sur ses
franges rappelle que vous êtes le
président de l'association acer actions
sécurité éthique républicaine merci
beaucoup